Do you ever wish you could go behind the scenes
of your favourite TV show to see how it gets
made?
Some people would probably say no -- it might
ruin the magic for them.
But most people would probably love to see
what it’s like on the set of Game of Thrones
or The Walking Dead.
Is it really as exciting as they make it look
in the finished product?
Here are 10 Behind the Scenes Facts You Never
Knew About Popular TV Shows.
If you like it, why not subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more videos like this one!
The meth is actually candy in Breaking Bad
In Breaking Bad, Bryan Cranston plays Walter
White, a high school teacher who turns to
crystal meth manufacturing when times get
bad.
Wearing nothing but his underwear and a gas
mask, White cooks up some primo product in
his trailer, which is tinted blue and actually
looks kind of tasty.
But what was the meth ? According to a radio
interview with Bryan Cranston, all the meth
was made of cotton candy-flavoured rock candy,
and actors would often eat it during long
days on set, just to get a little bit of energy.
The kids who auditioned for Stranger Things
had to read the script for Stand By Me
Stranger Things is a series that wears its
influences on its sleeves, and one of those
influences is the classic 80s film Stand By
Me, based on a novel by Stephen King.
Though it’s set in the 1950s, the film tells
a story about a similar group of boys, who
travel out into the forest to see a dead body.
Apparently, the casting director had prospective
actors read lines from the script to Stand
By Me while they were auditioning.
It was just that important that the new actors
captured the same feeling as the older film.
Dan Harmon and Chevy Chase fought on the set
of Community
The cult hit comedy Community attracted a
devoted group of fans with its smart and self-aware
riffs on pop culture.
But even though the characters of the show
were one big family, the drama behind the
scenes could get pretty brutal.
Chevy Chase, who played Pierce, a cranky old
man from the study group, hated working for
Dan Harmon, who created the show.
The feud got so bad that Harmon was actually
fired at the end of season 3.
But when Chase walked off the set at the end
of season 4, NBC brought Harmon back to wrap
up the series.
The wreckage was a part of the score of Lost
Fans of the cult hit Lost know that the series
begins with one heck of a plane crash, which
is pretty epic for a network TV series.
They might also know that the score, created
by Michael Giacchino is a creepy, unsettling
affair that also leaves room for a lot of
emotion attachment.
What they might not know is that Giacchino
used actual pieces of that wreckage to use
for percussion on the show’s original score.
The wreckage was scavenged after the shoot
and brought to the recording studio, where
Giacchino has his way with it.
Perhaps that’s why it’s so unsettling?
Parks and Recreation was originally a spinoff
of The Office
A fast-paced mockumentary about about a workplace
full of loveable -- but sometimes frustrating
-- human beings?
A boss who lacks self-awareness and is prone
to embarrassing situations?
You could be describing The Office -- or you
could be describing Parks and Recreation,
which was co-created by Greg Daniels, who
also adapted The Office for American television.
In fact, he originally envisioned Parks and
Rec as a spinoff to the hit Steve Carrell
show, but changed his mind after a few months
of toying with idea in development.
Still, nobody would have been surprised if
Dwight Schrute showed up in Pawnee at some
point.
Luck got cancelled because horses kept dying
Back in 2012, HBO thought it had another hit
on its hand with Luck, a series about a horse-racing
track starring Dustin Hoffman.
The series was created by David Milch, the
mastermind behind Deadwood and NYPD Blue.
The series premiered to good reviews, but
it got cancelled anyway.
The reason?
The horses on set kept dying.
Two horses were euthanized after getting injured
during the filming of the first season, and
when a third horse died during early production
of the second season, HBO pulled the plug
on the show, citing health and safety concerns.
Larry David voiced George Steinbrenner on
Seinfeld
When George Costanza gets a job with the New
York Yankees in Seinfeld, his boss was a version
of the real life George Steinbrenner, though
you never get to see his face and he sounded
a little different from the real thing.
If you’re wondering whose voice is coming
from behind Steinbrenner’s chair, it’s
Seinfeld co-creator Larry David.
His voice might seem familiar now, given that
David has starred in eight seasons of Curb
Your Enthusiasm, but at the time he was more
of a behind-the-scenes figure.
Though maybe it convinced him he could be
an actor?
Hank Azaria auditioned for the role of Joey
in Friends
Most people probably know Hank Azaria best
for his various voice roles on The Simpsons.
Moe, Chief Wiggum, Apu, Disco Stu…
It’s all Azaria.
But he also played Phoebe’s lover David
on Friends, a scientist who ended their relationship
to move to Minsk.
He eventually returned to New York, but Phoebe
ended up with Mike, played by Paul Rudd.
That wasn’t Azaria’s first rejection,
however.
He also auditioned for the role of Joey…
twice!
To be honest, though, we’re pretty glad
Joey wasn’t played by the same person as
Comic Book Guy.
Game of Thrones has an unaired pilot
Game of Thrones is one of the most popular
series on TV, but despite the chemistry of
the cast, it didn’t always look the way
it does now.
In fact, HBO filmed an entire pilot with a
different director and some different cast
members.
This version was directed by Thomas McCarthy,
who also made the Oscar-winning Spotlight,
but maybe wasn’t quite the right choice
for a Westeros-set drama.
Daenarys Targaryen and Catelyn Stark were
played by different actors, too.
Still, HBO saw the promise, so they picked
up the series and let DB Weiss and David Benioff
rewrite and reshoot the first episode.
We’re glad
that they did!
Last suppers in The Walking Dead
Fans of The Walking Dead know that no one
is safe.
Anybody on that series could die at any time.
Such is the nature of a zombie-infest post-apocalyptic
world.
So do the cast and crew do anything to cope
with the loss of a long-time colleague?
Actually, they do.
The night before filming a major death scene,
the crew puts on a “Last Supper” for the
principal actors, giving the doomed actor
a chance to eat whatever they want, just like
the prisoners on death row.
It’s really the least they can do for their
soon-to-be-unemployed co-star.